hello everybody we are live with the
long anticipated king of tick tock uh
comedian extraordinaire
[Applause]
Howie Mandel in studio I'm so nervous
Howie's nervous why are you nervous
Howie why am I nervous yeah I'm not
because you're here right I'm nervous
because you're here do you have some
Trauma from the episode we did on your
well first of all I will say I can't
thank you enough for coming onto my
podcast yeah Howie Mandel does stuff
yeah and uh because and you said it it's
it's the most clicked episode we've ever
had by far thank you and I get I get
like big like this week we have Jimmy
kimmelon we have uh nobody cares nobody
cares no but but I'm saying we have he
cares about Jimmy Kimmel we have
everybody anybody Mark Norman Ari
shaffir is is on today that's who I did
it today and no matter who I've had on
you have doubled the amount
[Applause]
we don't do ours in front of an audience
like you do and um you I chased you down
I stalked you in Malibu you and you was
it funny yeah it was yeah because I knew
that you had this big following and I
had seen a couple of shows since you've
been on I watch you all the time now oh
thank you you don't have to think cool
I'm I'm traumatized you do every day
because you share things that I'm not
comfortable with but but the the thing
is that and you're you're following who
I'm not knocking were very hard on me
they were yeah
[Music]
right well we talked about you like a
million yeah no I know but when he was
there I was trying to do I thought I was
trying to do uh I was afraid of you
talking about
um yeah in a pro it's appropriate what
oh that was a sound bite of you going ow
but oh other people hear that right yeah
yeah yeah no because if I hear Boys in
my head I heard myself going now how did
I hurt myself yeah I'm just freaked out
can you just go easy yeah there's gonna
be sound bikes throughout so don't you
everybody hears I know but you have no
idea how nervous I am scared I seem
skittish yeah um I brought my son with
me today just go be careful like I don't
know if I'll get in trouble he's here to
give you the kibosh on things because
this is live I don't work live
um you were nice enough to show up and
give us the biggest uh audience we ever
had for one episode and so I felt like I
would return you tried to get me back
you've gotten me um you've made me
uncomfortable for uh
I've made mistakes and then you shine
lights on oh you're talking about prolab
I wasn't but yeah I mean I was trying to
say it without my lights inside the
prolapse I did not okay shut down
obviously the prolapse Howie's Tick Tock
prolapse I I've always felt so
talk about that oh come on you've been
dodging first of all too long I have
been dodging it can I just wait hold on
one sec this episode's sponsored by
honey thank you like what honey honey
yeah just general
my honeybees yeah you like honey you you
were sponsored by honey yes sir that's
like saying it's brought to you by Bread
yeah no it's like milk it's just bread
has us we're huge but it's not even a
brand of it it's just the thing just the
association for honey you know this is
brought to you by honey yeah you know
how like back in the 90s they used to
run milk commercials and they're like
this commercials brought to you by the
milk Association of America and they'd
be like got milk it's the same thing the
honey people have all came together
honey people it's been big honey
it's not people it's these yeah okay so
the bees came together and they paid me
to say that well this week's episode of
Howie Mandel does stuff is brought to
you by water yeah yeah that's very good
yeah but Honey's pain
water is important actually some would
say anyway very important okay so you
stopped for honey and now I have lost my
train of thought well hold on a question
yeah so so hold on okay I just want to
let you know you have nothing to worry
about okay now this is when it sounds
like I'm getting my prostate checked
when my friend Neil bend over oh no come
on
about it
oh my God I'm fine people
oh my God
okay all right number one podcast in the
world
I'm growing my hair back people my
friend Neil my my friend Neil nothing
nothing else
oh
somebody know is this covered relay oh
my God
[Music]
[Applause]
so welcome to the show we did that just
to kind of you know make you comfortable
and at home let you know that we're all
fans everybody's on the signaling are
you doing anything are we okay Alex am I
okay get a thumbs up so can I just say
something I just want to say something
okay so that's a mistake that was a
mistake debatable
it's not debatable I'm telling you you
don't know me that was a mistake
can I be enough I thought it was going
to play again I thought I heard a noise
oh one more time guys I took it down
okay I did and I took it down right away
here's the thing well no it was up for
like 17 hours nope yes it was Howard no
it wasn't is that your whole name yes it
is when people are mad at me how was it
up for 17 hours Alex
yeah he's Alex said yes I slept for
through through it so it was right
before I went to bed yeah I saw this
picture where did you see that picture
um oh so so on Tick Tock I sometimes go
like weird or I'll look up like weird or
gross oh I just looked that up for
content just whatever you know wait wait
wait hold on backtrack you went to
Google you typed weird or gross yeah and
you somehow found a way to a prolapsed
anus I didn't know that oh you didn't
know what it was no oh what did you
think it was really I thought it was
gross I thought it was a wet cake stuck
to Somebody's Ass no red shirt yeah why
do you know what are you serious Alex is
that true
yeah
I did not know oh my God I did not know
what it was it just looked I just
thought randomly I'm gonna put up this
gross picture and I'm gonna go is this
covet related did I know that the pwpa
had such a power or such a like a he
people with prolapsed anesis it's an
acronym
like uh to the wolf that's like the
walkway to prefer to them I didn't know
what it was yeah so my I'm being honest
with you I swear I didn't know the
minute you said it was debatable the
debate I meant debatable if it's a
mistake because it's like such a
phenomena it's not a phenomenon it is
this is a phenomenon wait a minute I
want to say this no that prolift has
brought a lot of people a lot of Joy
yeah that's what I meant the prolapse
has brought a lot of people a lot of joy
and you need to know that yeah what do
we do about it
yeah I'm sorry to cut you off I just
want you to know that you know you did
it I think I didn't do it on purpose if
then then there's joy by by accident I
didn't know what it was I thought it was
like wet pudding on the back of somebody
pudding it looked like a wet pudding
didn't it look like wet pudding on the
back of a red shorts
there was these red shorts and there was
things I did I swear to you I didn't
know what did you think then you think
think he [ __ ] himself I thought maybe he
was feeling like it was a plastic bag
and maybe pooping in the bag I didn't
know what it I didn't know you're making
me think about it more than had I
thought about it I probably wouldn't
have posted it wow so I put it up just
saying because I was making uh a joke as
debatable like is this covid related
that I put it up and I went to sleep
that's why I didn't know it was it was
uh 17 hours so I put it up and I went to
sleep every day I post on Tick Tock so I
I go to sleep within about five hours
Alex who's sitting over there my son
calls me and goes what did you do dad
and I go he did and I go what do you
mean what did I do because you're
trending on on Twitter on worldwide yeah
you're trending I didn't I've been
sleeping like what what did I do he goes
what did you do on Tick Tock and I go I
got a picture of a wet pie I got a
picture of a wet pie up and I'm just
asking if it's from covid and he goes
it's that's not what he told me my son
says that no that's a prolapsed anus and
I said what is a I don't even know what
a prolapsed I don't even I don't even
know what do you know not funny oh this
is so fun but you know what I don't know
what it is but you know what it is now
oh it's like so I think we've debated it
I think the picture in question it was a
prolapse of pleasure I think what I
think yeah no so there's two different
times of prolapses one you take off
massive steamer and your colon just
falls out of your ass that's or like you
power lift or something yeah but this
wait wait wait why is that the same
thing as if you take a [ __ ] or your
power lift is that the same
and that's the same well there's like
there's like a minor prolapse where your
your intestines just falls out of your
[ __ ] but the one that you showed this
is the Atlanta sound guys
[Laughter]
we're really good that's Zach
I love you Howie yeah I love you too
he's the best
I'm really nervous okay so okay the one
that you posted I believe you're doing
we're not making fun we're just this is
a sign like you're just teaching now I
just want to make sure that people know
that I didn't know I didn't know what it
was yeah and I'm here to learn go ahead
yeah so there's a there's an accidental
prolapse and then there's an intentional
prolapse which is a prolapse of pleasure
which I think some some groups of men or
women or enjoy prolapsing their anus as
part of a sexual act wait enjoyed
prolapsing like you can do that on
purpose yes apparently there's people
that do it on Earth debatable
and we'll get into that a little bit
later well I don't want to get into it
no no yes no no so listen I took it down
no I want to be honest here and that's
why I'm here listening okay so I took it
down
then
the and the more the fact that I took it
down it blew up even bigger and then you
did not help me it's not funny it's not
funny I'm being serious you didn't help
me because I watched you Abby I've
watched you after you were on my show
and there isn't an episode that I
haven't seen where you're not flashing
it in front of somebody's face you're
not asking them to react you also create
and your viewers create memes that live
forever there is a plethora of people
who say they won't forget and they're
looking for apologies I don't even know
what I'm supposed to apologize for I did
a whip I posted uh inadvertently a wet
piece of cake on somebody's tush yeah
and then and then wait wait I didn't say
anything no I know but I'm really
uncomfortable and I chat says they love
you I lost a fortune I then I got called
by uh sponsors and who walked away from
me Tick Tock sponsors are just General
sponsors General really why so sensitive
apparently it's a big deal I didn't I
didn't even know it existed and which
one do you lose
a lot we're talking seven figures or six
um you don't have to say you don't have
to say if you're not comfortable I'm not
I'm not comfortable before you ask me
the question yeah okay not only that so
that they they got upset with me
and uh I just tried to stay away from it
and every time I tried to stay away from
it you have this huge platform you can't
run from it Howie you have to embrace it
it's a beautiful moment did you see it
it's wet but some men embrace it out of
love and effect I can't believe somebody
can do that well you'll find out I don't
want to find out and I'm here to put an
end to the the hysteria I didn't know
what it was I took it down I now know
what it is apparently I I don't know
exactly what it is different types of
prolapses I don't care intentional and
pleasure why would somebody can I just
ask you something yeah why would I saw
the picture and I put it up because I
thought it was one of the grossest
things I've ever seen and I didn't think
here's the problem if you didn't know it
was a prolapse how could you think it
was that gross because it just looked
icky okay it wasn't racist it wasn't
anti-semitic no it wasn't I wasn't and
I've never had this kind of hoopla for
what is like what who am I offending
like what am I offending that's my point
who did I offend nope not money and
nobody's offended why are you laughing
sorry it's so funny
[Applause]
you posted a prolapse Howie I by
accident when I took it down it doesn't
matter I didn't know why does it matter
if it was intentional okay and I didn't
know why would I do I didn't it was on
in an unintentional unintentional I
believe you though why does it make it
better I got in trouble I want to be a
good person if I if somebody sponsors me
I wanna that's why you have honey and I
don't yeah well remember that you have
Petty fresh stuff this is my mark can I
get one I'll give you one I respect
stuff in fact they're sponsoring our
next episode you want to sell my merch
you're not a sell merch you can go it's
new you can tell me I like it some
people are some people are saying um or
what are they saying that you posting it
on accident is funnier and why is it
funnier because like when you get into
an accident when you think accident
that's like stepping into traffic I feel
like
a little bit of my career did I lost my
you've made it long enough let's just
Burn It To The Ground but um
really really good man I wasn't you have
no idea it doesn't go away
it builds character and it's going to
make you stronger is that what they told
you in the Israeli Army maybe I mean
that's what he does like every week
really we lose sponsors and that really
sucks that I feel for you yeah just that
you don't need that brand you just get
things yeah honey you get stuff no stuff
is I'm selling we sold over three three
of these already it's really cute though
seriously can you tell me how to we just
it's the first time I've never sold
merch oh okay well that's a good one if
you're only starting it looks like yeah
it is really I like the acid wash really
good thank you and how much is that
shirt
I don't know you got to click on my like
you know like on on where do they go
Howie Mandel Howie mandel.com go click
just to see the price somebody will tell
me the price but no if you work on it
and tell me what it is and while you're
there subscribe listen Howie if you want
to sell merch just put something like is
this covid related no you haven't
it's a rogue you sent me stuff that you
know what I I got like I couldn't fall
asleep one night you sent me a picture
of a woman on the freeway oh yeah it's
not funny wait wait wait wait wait wait
you know what I'm talking about wait I
thought you liked it because you
responded well I responded I was I did
but you're the prolapse king that's
that's what you're talking about that's
somebody who does it on purpose yes yes
yes yes yes so it was like she was
breathing through her butt yeah so it's
going in and out like uh like a you know
when you see it like a lung yeah like a
lung yeah was there was there is there
is there a flow like why who said
pleasure yeah I don't understand what
they can they do that no I didn't know I
have to I know I have to admit that I
also didn't know that that was a thing
that was possible no but you didn't when
you saw my picture do you know what it
was you know what's crazy I never go on
Tick Tock yeah but I was there to
witness your prolapse I saw
yeah it's good price oh that's well now
they're just checking prices nobody's
buying they're just checking the prices
I like their shopping around listen you
put that prolapse on the shirt you'll be
you'll be you're gonna double your
network okay I'm just saying you asked
me for advice and now you don't want it
um so I saw it and I was in
ooh swipe why because all the [ __ ] that
he puts up that gun yeah I won't look at
it either yeah me and Dan we both
refused to even watch it for a long time
you'd have to watch it it was a still it
was me going is this covid related that
I made up a name this is my friend Neil
and then you look at all the people
going you know he showed his friends
like I had a guy named Neil bend over I
want to get a picture of this that's
crazy yo it's just did you see it's a
Snapchat filter now no it's not like
that link that up
you made it oh dude it's still good it's
never gonna go away I came here to put
an end to it oh please where am I
looking why are they applauding they see
something I don't see Amy's gonna send
me the link no we're gonna put it on the
TV yeah there's gonna put it on the
table hopefully it comes to tick tock
soon this is safe to show right baby no
no no no no no I don't want to be the
same thing filter and I'm very excited
about this is
[Laughter]
Alex
you can come look I I
was what if you want to live feed you
can sit back there look look it's at the
filter look at the filter show them the
filter play that one more maybe I should
guys there's a new Snapchat filter
you love it Howie look at you I know I
know that it's funny okay good I'm just
not I'm just not familiar with why I'm
so much backlash it's not bad
people are just enjoying it it's not
backlash nobody's mad at you yesterday
everyone's just we will always remember
people are kidding it's a joke it's a
joke when they take away a check no that
one you lost the check what does that
means
they're idiots they're all losers yeah
except except the ones that stick with
you honey honey stick with you I see
what you did
that's amazing she is a branding genius
what okay and that was unintentional but
I'll take it take it I'll take it yeah
then don't say it I I feel like I feel
like I have to admit no I would take it
okay yeah don't don't admit but um are
you not getting along what I don't know
what I was gonna say is um sponsors are
the most fair weather friends you can
have it's like you do one [ __ ] slip
up and they say peace forever that you
know there's no loyalty and so but the
people in your comments I have to assure
you that it's all love it is yeah I
promise it's all love because this this
is Tick Tock of the Year Howie whenever
we say we're not gonna forget that's not
like we're upset the last time people
said we will never forget that it wasn't
a good that was it well well Howie well
Howie I have to tell you that prolapse
was like my second 9 11.
why why
when the plane hit my butthole man when
the plane hit that button explained to
me that the one explained to me what
like with the pleasure one yeah so um
here I'll read you I have an excerpt for
you an excerpt there's a whole book on
it so rectal prolapse is one part of the
rectum bulges we know that we know that
um so can you get me a little blurb I I
don't want to get anything wrong about
pleasure prolapses please I could read
to Howie I love that he's in a position
where he goes can uh somebody just get
me a pleasure pull prolapse slurp oh
yeah you don't want to see my Google
this is a well-oiled machine how it but
that's probably where the pleasure
starts and trust me
yeah you need a lot of oil this is a
well-oiled machine am I getting in
trouble Alex no you're fine
when you saw the prolapse for the first
time what was your reaction
you called him you said what did you do
no you didn't see the prolapse you saw
the Twitter yeah and then and then do
you did you see at what point did you
see the prolapse
you said what'd you do he said what did
you do
what it's funny
you posted an [ __ ] I go no I didn't
the [ __ ] is covered by a wet cake
yeah but I said I did I did I said it to
him there's no [ __ ] in my picture
it's totally covered with a pink wet
cake if you weren't so beautifully naive
uh it never would have happened so it's
almost like your naivety
that's not what you're doing canceled
check said to me yeah [ __ ] them tell
them go shove the Chuck up their own
prolapse ass no I'm not you know I like
to keep my work I like where I work I
like the people I work for I like the
sponsors I don't have honey but I like
the spot for it maybe they'll come back
come back someday that honey what is
that this is uh this is a different this
is a gamer sub you want one what is it
it's gamer sub it's another sponsor it's
like an energy drink energy drink
yeah yes okay and what's GG that's the
same thing this is the powder you put in
the water oh so you get energy you're
getting it's got caffeine it tastes good
it's sugar-free
yeah okay so a lot of fluid Howie let me
read this to you well this Waters and
everything what is with all the drinks
well we're talking you know we're
talking a lot you want me to remove the
drinks I mean no no don't remove I don't
want I don't want to make any
suggestions okay yeah suggestions get me
in trouble oh my God if you know what's
bothering me I don't know if you can see
the pictures of your dogs can they see
that oh the dogs but they just they were
running around yeah and going crazy and
you said everybody said are you worried
about dogs I said no and then we sat
down and I started talking and they both
went to sleep I'm boring animals yeah
well they don't understand what you're
saying
if they could they'd be having a good
time music I love that okay keep the
music going
yeah so rectal prolapse is when you're
rectum the last section of your large
intestine drops and pushes through your
anus in the anal sex Community
especially those who identify as gay
this is commonly referred to as a
rosebud and the act of pushing it out is
known as blooming
how does that make you feel
I don't know I don't know I don't want
to talk about it Rosebud and yeah
and and only fans version of The
Bachelor do you accept my Rosebud
my Rosebud is blooming
the screen what
that's our safer work at it oh it's a
rose yeah beautiful so people at home
can watch when people engage in
excessive anal play especially with
large toys and fisting and over douching
I don't want to be sitting here well you
asked for me oh I didn't ask I asked you
to explain I didn't want a lot of words
I don't that doesn't matter it doesn't
matter we don't have to know ignorance
is bliss well it got you in trouble this
time if you weren't so ignorant you
wouldn't have posted a damn flowering
prolapse did you try the last thing that
came to mind was flowers when I saw what
I saw wait honey I got you a bouquet can
I please finish this guys I have a show
to do over douching they ran the risk of
losing
apparently like that's a lot of douching
what's that like uh
I'm a germaphobe when have you ever said
to somebody you're overdouched you're
overdoing you're over douched man don't
don't do that you've douched enough
so oh well here here's the thing if
you've overdosed do they run the risk of
losing muscle tone which can lead to a
prolapse a rectal prolapse another
culprit yeah I know I don't look like
I'm in shape but I've got great muscle
tone
my my my intestines day right inside my
[ __ ] look at how I've toned my muscle
another closer Equinox I'm doing as we
sit here I'm doing pickles you know that
are you really I am it's good don't
laugh don't laugh I have uh I have a
sick sack a thick sack it's like a six
pack yeah but it's just that's wonderful
you're what your wife is a very lucky
lady I know
another culprit is blooming which is
quite popular within certain communities
people love to bloom and are asked to
bloom by their partner which can have
long term okay and her ass to bloom by
their Partners can you imagine
Bloom for yeah no Bloom for me yeah I
would love to bloom for you I would love
you know what I would love you want to
go to a movie not tonight you know what
I would love I would love love to bloom
I would love for you to bloom for me I
would love to bloom for you please I
would that would mean a lot it's like
nothing says spring
like a me blooming for you well there's
one ending sentence here I want to do we
support all the ways in which people
engage however we want to understand
over time the bloom won't resemble the
beautiful flower it once did so they're
saying what the blooming will over time
as all things gold must die as they say
uh uh the flower the petals fall off and
the bloom wasn't once uh the same it was
the bloom can get worn out a second oh
so there's only like
how many blooms you get for
how many balloons how many licks to get
to the center
thank you
that's that's the time old question
isn't it I mean I'm not a philosopher
but uh what do we do about it okay so
here's the next thing I want to do I
hate the sound of my voice people
we have a bunch of sound bites that we
use of you on the show I wanted to give
you the uh Anthology go ahead go ahead
Zach the number one podcast in the world
and you said that to Simon Cowell I did
who's a [ __ ]
loser no oh okay no he's a winner he's a
winner I'll be honest with you so number
one he has the most successful
television show in history do you know
that is it really it really is so uh Got
Talent is in
150 markets in like Asia's Got Talent
really
crazy that's the it's called a format
and the format is the most and and just
to give you an idea of how successful
that is I know for a fact that he makes
much more money from that than he made
for music and think about this at one
time he had five of the top 10 Billboard
charting songs you know from one
direction to uh and yet he can't get
more views than me on your podcast
and that makes them a loser
when he competes with me
okay so humble
he is humble that's what I meant that's
all I wanted to say oh yeah yeah oh
that's amazing though by the way that's
pretty what part you can Bloom three
times and then the leaves fall off yes
is that what you're saying yeah it is
amazing when you think about it yeah so
um go ahead Zach when my friend Neil
bent over this happened it didn't and
that's not Neil and then you know is
this related what are we doing what do
we do about it right ow ow you remember
ow ow like poetry isn't it yes it is it
really is
but I think it's funny if the picture
looks funny and then it's not what it is
and it wasn't a ball sack I didn't show
a ball sack I showed a bird right right
I thought I showed a wet piece of
pudding on the back of somebody's pants
I don't know what I'm doing did you tell
the sponsors that that's what you
thought
the sponsors go we think this is
inappropriate I go I don't I don't know
I don't what is it that what is that
this was I just want to show off a
reference that I'm growing my oh that
I'm growing my hair back people Howie
that's a nutsack
I don't know what it is is it something
bad people I just find these pictures
what is that well ask a viewer I think I
think it it's something fake someone
made just to go viral that's not a nut
sack you don't put you're not supposed
to put don't close up on it you know you
don't zoom in on it it's a plan look get
that it's a plant yeah
yeah oh that's that guy does a lot of
weird things he has a living banana
that's providing I go to his go to that
on on Tick Tock that that name I always
do at him he's got a banana that lives
oh so by the way you're mentioning how
the comments are unforgiving yeah let's
just take a look we won't forget Howie
but you understand that's not hate right
like on a serious no you know that
they're not like actually mad that's
just a meme everyone's just having a
good time is that fun yeah I promise you
this there this is love this is love it
really is it's just a joke everyone's
just loving it can't we just be can't we
just be platonic two it is pretty yeah
well they don't want that you know
they're not asking you to pro-lapse but
I'm sure they would eat it up but I got
in trouble I don't want to get in
trouble anymore
um I do not want to get keep getting
away yeah see that that's what I said to
you
is it a good thing that I'm yes so I'm
curious um crispy chicken sandwich what
is it crispy they just strike too I
guess this first one being the pro lab
go to that guy go to his thing that his
name is on there no go to go to show me
the what you think is a nut sack yeah go
to the picture and his name's uh what's
that who did I do the duet with this guy
yeah go look at his bananas are living
which one should I click uh go to that
go to even that this one yeah it's a
piece of baby lamb burger is refusing to
eat
yeah he just he makes really fun look
there it goes there it goes and it falls
off why is that a bad thing it falls off
they just come and they fall off I don't
think the prolapse is a bad thing either
no but that's why I go to a million of
that that guy he's got a million I love
him I see these wet things and falling
and crawling and I go I want to be part
of this I'm curious of the Fallout so
you post it in the morning Alex calls
you he goes yo what have you done I want
that tonight yeah you posted at night
you fell asleep then I go to sleep a lot
of people like to hear stories listen to
music or watch Netflix I look for
something wet and icky a picture like
that guy stuff and then I'll put my face
next to it and say something and then
it's good night yeah and then I get a
phone call from my son he says what have
you done you guys what have you done is
never a good no question he doesn't say
how are you dad he just hi it goes what
have you done I'm not funny okay so then
you find out oh my God I posted a
prolapse so what do you do I didn't know
it was a prolapse you he didn't say you
did something wrong I go what what have
I done I go what are you talking about
he goes your Tick Tock what did I say to
you you didn't say it's a prolapsed anus
what did I say to you what did you say
to me
yeah he said that you can't post nudity
and I went there I didn't post nudity
the guy is wearing wet red pants and
there's cake on the back so funny and so
you went straight to tick tock you
erased it right right away and then did
you start getting calls from sponsors
like how did that Fallout go my agent
called me in the morning okay okay
shortly after this conversation no it
was in the next morning okay next
morning I took a whole day yeah and I'm
not gonna uh reveal their names but he
goes this uh account is really upset
about your posting and I go I took it
down they go well you're still trending
and people captured it and they're
posting it and uh go look at go look at
H3 no yes yeah he did no he didn't he
did no he did he did no he did it yes he
did a guy from WME he said go look at
what he posted no [ __ ] way he did no
why is that awesome I'm glad he he real
recognized real what yeah well he goes
it's not because I said it's gone
because it's not gone I just want to
make it clear I am not the sole reason
and driving force behind this you are
the biggest platform that keeps uh keeps
it alive thank you
I like when you call me a big platform
the number one podcast in the world and
so your agent called you and he says I'm
getting calls from these uh companies
who are not happy what are you gonna do
about it yeah what are we going to do
about it what do we do about it okay so
I I said I'll I'll apologize you want me
to apologize and I give me the number to
the agency or the the people that from
the company and I'll call them and I
called each and every one of them oh wow
and that didn't help no because it
existed and I said I'm really sorry I
didn't know what I would I didn't know
that it was a bad thing I didn't think
it was I didn't think it was nudity I
didn't think it was racist political and
he's a medic I don't know what it was
and they go no it's it's it's nudity and
I go but I didn't even recognize it as a
part of the body I didn't and I took it
down yeah and they go well we would like
to distance ourselves oh my God at this
moment we would like to death
so they did that and I said you know I
can't say anything to you but I'm sorry
and it won't happen again because from
now on I'm going to ask what what is
this that's why I knew that you can go
to that other site because I knew it was
just a living banana wet living banana
eating other pieces of things and so you
get on the call and what's the
conversation like are they pissed are
they understanding are they nice just on
just uncomfortable it's imagine I've
been married for like 42 years so I
don't know what dating is like but it's
like a date that's not going well
because these people have engaged me you
know like that they're in business with
me so what if you guys have been married
a long time but what if you're on a date
and you kind of run out of conversation
or you feel like you said something that
you shouldn't have said so I would go hi
it's it's Howie they go yes
oh I go well I know that you're I heard
that you
um my agent called me and said that
you're uncomfortable with the posting
and I'd like to I'm just calling you to
tell you to assure you that that won't
happen again
I took it down
um I didn't I didn't mean anything
offensive and to be totally honest with
you I don't unders I don't know what it
is I still don't know what a prolapse is
and I may never
I didn't end and I just found out today
that you can do it on purpose oh yeah it
only lasts for three blooms okay is that
what is that what it was they weren't
specific about the amount but just that
all things gold Must Die essentially you
should have gold must die yeah you
should have offered to bloom for them
maybe I wouldn't know how to do it I
know I'm well toned but I wouldn't know
how to how would you do that
I don't
know how you do it
I know
um Nothing Gold how do you say Nothing
Gold Can Stay it's a Robert Frost poem
of course oh I love that would you like
me to read that to you it's a Robert
Frost poem yeah it's short I would love
to hear about them put up some music
yeah
give me something how do you say
prolapsed anus in Hebrew good question
that's a good question I have no idea no
let me try to find out where do you find
it something more emotions you know this
one's okay this one's good okay go ahead
nature's first green is gold
her heart is Heel To Hold
her early leaves a flower but only so an
hour
then leave some side to Leaf so Eden
sank to grief so don goes down today
Nothing Gold Can Stay ow
e it yeah
Robert Frost Great American poet
and that was about that was about the
prolapse
uh can we get a tissue for Howie
in Hebrew
go ahead
oh the hell hole
which is like dunking like oh [ __ ] oh
wow see I thought it was a cake thank
you
um maybe not dunking something like
falling falling
I call it it's like the rectal falling
rectum that's fun it's like a it's
almost like a carnival game yeah it
sounds so much better in Hebrew doesn't
it funny yeah no Nick what's wrong
I'll call it
oh I love it English is so much better
oh we got the music going hey
everybody's wrecked and fall hey
hey and now we must be
just a minute hey you know just a minute
everybody the women
they can they can and then everyone's
bouncing like a yo-yo hey hey you hate
your partner proxy prolapse hey
[Laughter]
yes or how many was it two okay two and
they must have been like super clean
Brands I mean that seems like overly
cautious yeah yeah and have any of them
without telling you what it was but one
was a back to school campaign right I
just couldn't see the challenges on that
back
and have any of them come back no no no
yeah well no but there's always honey I
think they might though you lose I can
give it like a year yes oh just give it
like you say that like that's nothing
just write me a nice check don't worry
bro it's a year I've lost I mean I'm
married to this guy banned twice this
year and I've both times lost a bunch of
sponsors but they come back
they come back yeah they do and I've
done way worse [ __ ] than posters
apparently I didn't even know what it
was and you don't know there's nothing
well you remember the the bomb that uh
no no no no no don't do that I don't
want to talk about it he's not allowed
to talk I'm just saying that was way
worse that's way worse than approaching
yeah you did what you did was worse than
the color and then I got recently
another suspension did you see the Ben
Shapiro thing or did you yeah yes no I
saw that I saw that yeah we won't talk
about that either I'm not getting
dragged into anything no even here we're
not I have enough trouble with the
Nicholas now from now on when people all
right so wait a minute the bald guy is
that hold it Howie so I just have to
thank our sponsor real fast just one
sponsor
and then afterwards we I know you're
professionally a judge at this point in
your life AGT so we have we have a fam
risk oh okay well let's do it let's take
it oh wow spam risk I don't know what
that means spam code hello yeah
hello
speaker hello
hi my name is Jake
here okay how are you doing today I'm
okay
I'm gonna be 67. I think it's a bot yeah
I'm gonna be 67.
and I have a name
wait ask him a question about when
people answer
except
can I just tell you something I'm 67
years old it's so uh it's amazing that
you would call me at this time
I had the um I don't know if I could
still be insured but my my nihal has how
holla did
uh so you know do you have some life
insurance at the moment no no
no problems we disqualified those people
who are above 45 below 70 you know I'm
60. I'm I'm 67. but I will be totally in
full yes 67 years old full disclosure
I posted in Nicole Hal hollett
is that okay
you do understand that
we understand great oh yeah hung up on
me what how annoying am I that I can't
even get the dogs
spam guy and they hung up on you because
that's crazy nobody wants to be a part
of a nikhaila Hal Holland if only he
knew what a big fish he had on the line
um so we're going to thank our sponsor
and we come back I have a challenge that
I'm going to judge yeah I want you to
judge it's a talent act someone a few
things where do I go during this uh
sponsor you can go to the bathroom you
can hang out or you're telling me to
leave no you don't have to you can sit
right there it's just a minute it's fun
you can find out what the [ __ ] honey is
no I didn't say that I said what the
[ __ ] honey is honey I can't yeah I
actually I'm not supposed to curse
during these please Howie I didn't first
no prolapse talks right now okay we're
on a prolapse band today's episode is
sponsored by PayPal honey the easiest
way to save when shopping on your iPhone
or computer
PayPal honey yeah yeah PayPal bought
honey isn't that wonderful what a great
family of uh they PayPal owns all honey
wait honey an app to do something yeah
it's a Chrome extension
why are you keeping me ignorant you want
me to know everything about the uh if we
teach you if we do nothing about your
spot if we teach you two if we teach you
too much about the world you won't be
posting prolapses we have to keep you a
little bit in the dark what
okay let's start over
I blame Howie
today's episode is sponsored by PayPal
honey the easiest way to save When
shopping on your iPhone or computer I
love honey actually you know what honey
is yeah the promos PG thing I've ever
heard about it's a Chrome extension and
what it does is it scours the internet
right and searches for coupons for your
favorite online retailers wow and it
automatically applies to that checkout
it really is magic I mean we save money
all the time ela's the queen of saving
with Hunter
of hundreds thousands of dollars so you
shop as usual yeah and you um it's an
extensions that you install once and
then it just works yes Chrome extension
they have it on iPhones now too Through
Safari okay so when you shop online
right you just add stuff to cart as
usual right you go check out and then it
works so if somebody went to
howiemandel.com and bought my new merch
stuff could they use could they use
honey no because you have to have an
active coupon code if you did then they
would then honey would have it you know
but then there's some websites will have
it and you miss it or you don't pay
attention so then when you go to
checkout it does it automatically yeah
so a lot of times I shop and then it's
like boom uh fifty dollars off for no
reason yeah I hear that sound boom yeah
it's honestly amazing I don't use the
internet without honey all these guys
here use it and with holiday shopping
coming up you're definitely going to
want to have that installed when you're
buying gifts uh for for your loved ones
there or your hated ones I mean they
need gifts too right anyway holiday
season I mean how many people do you
like yeah yeah we do Hanukkah
we do Christmas we do a little bit I
like yeah you know yeah like Chris yeah
yeah because it's a great pool it's not
good no no no no
uh you could save even more when you ask
honey to keep track of price drops on
your holiday shopping list if the price
drops on anything on your list you'll
get instantly an alert to let you know
that's interesting because on Amazon
those prices are all over the place you
go one day that's why I've been buying
pet food treats it's just like 20 swings
it's nuts so they're gonna keep track of
that and let you know when it's at its
cheapest price if you don't already have
honey you're straight up missing out and
by getting it you'll be doing your
self-assault and supporting this show
thank you I wouldn't recommend buy one
of those big Nets I want to get a net
why he's pulled me off stage no
catch butterflies with your mama oh [ __ ]
oh you know about my mom's butterfly
Obsession me and her are always catching
butterflies okay okay interest that's
nice I like that
um I love honey I use it all the time
get PayPal uh honey for free at
joinhoney.com H3 that's joinhoney.com H3
uh if you're not using this when you're
buying stuff you're basically
losing money it's fomo fomo big time
thank you honey we love you losing money
honey yeah
foreign
and take a I need to go pee so you you
guys carry the show for a minute you're
really gonna leave in the middle of a
show to pee it's a live show what can I
do I have to pee catheter oh right and
that it would be why would you leave the
audience for you who Do You Love More
your bladder or the audience oh well
what does that say oh my God they did it
oh they wrote it that says uh read it
but you guys need to do it the opposite
I can't read it without the vowels oh
yeah yeah that's a loser all right I'm
gonna run I'll be really fast and then
you guys are getting um the talent ready
yeah yeah they're ready to go how many
people are watching right now
I don't know I don't open
um
40 000. really
go subscribe to my pod yeah
there's a link in the just how powerful
this place is right let's see you you
had the most clicks let's see if I was
just saying they don't like when I'm on
your show they don't like whenever
you're gonna come back and come on
anytime you want Ali I want you to come
you've given both of you okay both of
you you've given so much to me I want
you I'm learning from you you are not
only entertaining but you're educating
that's it that's my passion is education
really it's my first Passion all right
I'm gonna go to the bathroom real fast
there's 40 seconds
all right
in the meantime yeah what do you want to
talk to me about
now it's just uncomfortable and awkward
when a guy invites you on the show he's
right go away for a minute while he does
his commercial for honey I didn't go
away I stayed I stayed so that we can
continue yeah and he goes away I know
wouldn't it be better to take a break
during the commercials
but he's got to do the commercial but
why doesn't he pee before the show he
did he's got to pee a lot really yeah
have you checked his prostate
no oh well maybe you should oh we're
back to the yeah
[Laughter]
just really from your perspective I'm
going to ask you seriously is this good
merch it's very good 35 is too cheap
it's too cheap yeah we'll get it until I
listen to her and and but there's always
Authority there's really forty dollars
at least well I just want people to wear
stuff I don't know the cost but when
whenever we do an acid wash it adds a
lot to the cost so so I'm giving it well
that's great I like that but my I told
you my daughter and my wife love teddy
fresh that's so cool yes my daughter my
well I I will do a whole package for
them and stuff would you she'll wear it
on my podcast my honor she'll wear it on
my podcast okay and we'll plug it and
not that you need us because we don't we
have a fraction of what you have but I
have Jackie Schultz Jacqueline Schultz
will wear she thinks that Teddy freshest
because I showed her she knew I was
coming here we just did a podcast right
before I came here yeah and I said I'm
going there and she goes our look at our
stuff compared to hers and it's actually
really good thank you how do you guys do
multiple shows in a day I feel like it's
so hard you're doing two hours in a day
we do one hour we do we had Ari shaffir
on you know Ari yeah I mean not
personally Arie shaffir he's got a
really good uh special on YouTube right
now called Jew
really yeah on YouTube he put it on
YouTube and within it's a full it's the
full uh stand up and within six days he
has over three and a half million Clips
on it and he asks people you could tip
it's like busking online yeah yeah but
you know his story no he was Hasidic he
went to Yeshiva in Jerusalem wow and
then he left that and now he's uh wow
that's really interesting yes guys we
have we have a tech issue it's stuck on
one shot the wide shot so we have to
restart vmix the stream actually what
shot are we stuck on it's the wide shot
it's this one with that one yeah
then you're like no
we could see you on that side pardon me
are you trying to get out of the shot no
I thought in the shot this way you're
there we can see you yeah
yeah so uh we're gonna reset um but but
the stream's not gonna go down right Dan
no
but it's going to keep this the episode
yeah okay we have to do this everybody
who's there will still be there we're
only going it's a technical issue we're
everyone the show's not ending it's
gonna go down and come right back up
yeah because we need to fix it so we can
show the talent and stuff okay go ahead
and restart it guys we're not going
anywhere this is scary no no no don't
worry oh no I'm scared let's go
yeah
foreign
[Music]
I love when the guy running it goes I
think we're back wait how do you know
we're back what why are you so sure
we're back
[Music]
where are you watching the screen
looking at you
I don't have a red butt and then from
the bathroom
okay we're back we're back how do you
know we're back wow why are you so sure
that's us we're back well I know there's
a delay
I'm a [ __ ] idiot it was my computer
oh my God all right you know we once
started an episode and I had the live
open
and um
I think it was dance was it me or you
Dan
but we had double audio for the first
three minutes of the whole [ __ ]
podcast was bad
not a great story well okay well no I
mean those are like one of those you
have to be there I think so yeah oh my
God I gotta tell you a story one time we
went live and there was a a delay in our
voice for over five minutes oh my God oh
my God and I'm sure the people at home
are commenting oh my God they remember
if that happened they remember it was my
911.
again you must never forget yeah we must
it's an audio it's audio hell okay so
yeah it's hard to listen compared to
prolapsing the excitement levels are not
there I agree weird I'm out of sync so
what do you
why did that happen we have the talent
ready program
oh we have talents ready yeah yeah he's
in the waiting room so let's bring Alan
our first uh Talent oh wow he's a great
guy actually someone I have the utmost
respect for okay and uh his name is
do I call him hunger is that hunger yeah
[Music]
wow
yeah this is I'm so excited for this so
bring on Hunger this is like a loyal it
really is all right like a prolapse
where am I looking well I don't even
know
hey hunger you're upside down is that
not part of it yay
I won't look he can't wear that shirt
oh oh yeah can you mind changing shirts
do you want me to yeah yeah I'm sorry we
just can't show I know after all that
after all that he says do you want me to
turn it off you can't wear the shirt he
can't wear the shirt tell him to change
his shirt and then he goes you want me
to
like it wasn't subtle no it had a URL to
a uh I'll explain it no no no maybe it's
trouble yeah trouble yeah it doesn't
matter yes it's bad it was stupid you
shouldn't have worn that shirt as a
judge you have no talents
no thank you thank you
sorry to make it is that the same shirt
inside out that was so fast I think it's
the same shirt inside out so so um is it
just me or does he look like his head's
on upside down
why because he's got a big old beard
yeah so how we please let me conduct
this go ahead yeah thank you so hunger
FF is that how you prefer me to address
you hunger
yeah okay Ryan or Ryan so either hunger
FF or Ryan so um hunger FF let's start
by showing your talent and then we can
kind of talk through it is that okay
yeah um just go ahead and do it right
now yeah just go ahead everything you
requested
oh my God oh my God oh
no no
no
oh you can oh
wait wait I made sure I had some hand
sanitizers on hand just in case that was
actually really impressive
oh my gosh no oh my we didn't show it at
home but hunger FF is actually a world
famous
um prolapser yeah oh my he's one of the
top in the field
now I understand what everybody was
talking about I had no idea that that so
you again
do you want to describe what just
happened we didn't show it what
is the worst thing I've ever seen
no no one bothers me that you have him
do that and that you don't have a
problem with that but you he comes up
and you go you can't wear that shirt
we couldn't show it
at home then he changes his shirt and
his whole butthole comes out but God
forbid we should see the shirt
oh my God we saw a shirt I'm just saying
they didn't see that at home they didn't
see what at home sure the prolapse I was
actually I was wondering if they were
gonna see that it was like how are they
gonna get away with showing this at home
no we didn't but where are you you can't
be in this building no no where are you
does it scare you might be in the
building it scares me that you're on
this planet
what did you what is that what is that
why do you do that
it's my tail
yeah let me take over so let me take
over a little bit so hunger what can you
describe for everyone at home what just
happened
he's this is a great guy
I have a ligament deficiency that
basically lets me turn my insights
inside and out wow okay so is that a
result of a ligament deficiency that
allows there's more than just a ligament
that you're deficient in
no no no no no no so like basically like
where are your organs and like
everything inside of you is like stuck
in place yeah and a little bit more so
you learned to do this mobile he goes
I'm mobile yeah yeah he's got attack
yeah so how we look behind you
oh if it's there I'm just kidding I'm
just kidding
[ __ ] out of me are you see in this
building no no he's not so is that the
result of hunger is that the result of
practice or just a natural god-given
ability that can't be practical practice
makes perfect
but like it was yeah it was a god-given
thing I mean like I was born with it I
mean for as long as I can remember I've
been able to break that wow and so
basically hunger FF stands for Hunger
fish festing he this is his profession
he is a professional uh he does this for
a living as part of the we call the
prolapsing for pleasure is that right
hunger
I mean like it was when I first started
doing it I mean it was definitely more
of a very small Niche fetish and then I
kind of
exacerbated it yeah yeah what do you
mean you franchise it's growing a little
bit into popularity since since I
started yeah now there's probably six
people that like it that's actually yeah
I'm surprised you like it did you ever
like freak out a doctor you go for a
prostate exam and then they do that and
the guy behind you goes holy you know
have you ever done that I went for a
colonoscopy one time just to kind of see
like what I didn't tell the doctor I
just kind of was like Hey I you know I
want to know kind of just make sure
everything's okay I'm down there
whatever
and I go in and he comes back after the
colonoscopy he's like why did you waste
my time
and I said why why what's wrong he's
like you're there's absolutely nothing
wrong with your insights and I was like
this this guy looked at the wrong chart
you looked at the wrong page but yeah
colonoscopy the doctor goes you wasted
my time yeah he's probably kidding I'm
assuming yeah so tell me I want to
explain to Howie because again how he's
not really understanding that you are
um
you are a really a Trailblazer in your
profession it's true it's true and you
participate in what's failblazer fit
yeah tail fist Fest can you explain
what's fistfest for Howie fist
I promise I don't bite yeah I didn't see
any teeth there sorry about how hunger
uh yeah I am very interested and I and I
respect by the way the talent and the
skill that you have and I just want to
say that uh I wish I had a a you would
get the brown buzzer
can you explain Fist Fest for us
yeah so fistfest is an event that
happens
um three times a year uh in of all
places in Augusta and Georgia but um
they basically do a um yeah it's kind of
randomly golfing and fisting so
um like three times a year this big kind
of convention where a bunch of guys come
together
um and just this for like three days
straight and they do like there's like
games and [ __ ] about like how many
fingers am I holding up yeah well I mean
there's all kinds of like I mean it's a
really fun thing I mean because most of
us are spread out around the country and
so those of us that like it it's kind of
like a big fist [ __ ] family reunion
yeah yeah yeah yeah so how many people
show up to Fish Fest it's huge there's
hundreds
and do you guys meet like did you guys
meet in like a conference hall or like a
big hotel room how does that go down
close off this entire Resort
because it's not very resort-esque but
it's it's like basically like a motel
complex
um and then
um the reason like this Fest kind of
blew up and and what happened with me ah
[ __ ] get out of there
um it's one of the uh one of the guys
for the festival I got
yeah no I got I got fisted on the back
of it was kind of an impromptu thing it
was in the beginning of my my time as
hunger FF I got fisted on the back of a
pickup truck at the at the event in the
parking lot and so it blew fist Fest up
it blew from Hunger effect up and one
thing led to another and here here I am
now okay that's interesting how so you
got fisted in the back of a pickup truck
and that clip went viral or something
yes okay wow that's interesting wow
because we just randomly we randomly
decided to do this and then grabbed like
some randomly
it got it was uh I got triple fisted on
the back of the truck oh my God that's
what I'm saying yeah hunger is the key
you know what I wish I would I wish I
knew but like I don't So Hunger are you
gonna happen hunger are you like maybe
the
um
the man who can take the most in his ass
is that a title that you hold or you
have competitors
uh I would definitely say since I mean
it used to be kind of like I felt like I
was kind of like
I would you know there but I have whole
Envy now for guys that I see on the
internet I'm like holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay
do you travel much yeah I travel for a
living basically I'm always on I'm never
home what do you mean you travel for a
living well he's a performer
yeah so like this is a full time this
pays the rent yeah
more yeah
but um no so I have subscribers that
follow me there and then like I just go
around the country and around the world
and film in different different places
all over the place so when you're
traveling and you have like carry on
yes
what am I what do you mean
I mean like where you don't have to put
it in the overhead
uh well because they can just tuck it in
my [ __ ]
yeah yeah
um yeah so hunger I mean I carry bags on
but I mean you know Mike I mean you know
but the extra stuff like your toothbrush
and stuff
oh yeah my toiletries all go straight up
so yeah so hunger so you're saying that
the competition is getting more fierce
in the in the world of kind of uh
fisting right what's the biggest yeah
what's the biggest thing you think you
fit in there
um well I mean like three three
-fifths was kind of a big accomplishment
I thought uh I mean like the biggest
people ask me that question I mean like
I've sat on traffic cones
oh my God why I'm trying to think like
off the top of my head what about a leg
you ever get a leg in there
when you sit on traffic cones does it
not um distract the drivers
do it right in the middle of traffic in
the middle of rush hour no sometimes
when you see that sign and it says Men
at Work you don't think you don't think
that's what you're right that's true
that's true but but I did I did take a
leg up to almost to the knee one time
wow and that's not the biggest
well it was a three months when they
mentioned that I thought of that I was
like oh yeah I did that that's right
and then when does
I have to look at my son while this
guy's on because
why
he's honestly I don't know a lot about
sports have you been on ESPN
not yet but yeah so I wanted to is it a
league
the fisting League is it a leak it
should be it should be yeah I wanted to
ask hunger um when you took the three uh
fists How deep did they go on the arm
so this was this was kind of this was so
crazy it was like it was this is what's
crazy now I'm gonna tell you he's got
three fists up his ass and he's going
wait let me explain you've never
explored in the bedroom how are you
you're better than this man this is
what's crazy you've never gone I can't
get over we almost saw his T-shirt I
can't I still can't get over that well
yeah we were I was getting double to
this website and my friend my friend
that was visiting me yelled over to the
side he's like he's like you want to try
a triple and so like this random dude
from the crowd just like wandered over
and was like I was like okay I guess
we're going for this and then the triple
happened and that's the way that the
video ends
um so I mean like it was they were both
I mean like there was like a there's a
finesse to it I mean like a way that it
goes in where oh you have to be around
your table gone yeah it works a mess and
jamming people's fists up your backside
should not be in the same sentence
really there's Elegance involved
they're absolutely there absolutely
should be finesse involved because if
there's nothing that's how you end up in
the hospital so right so what you're
doing is dangerous
it's like crossing the street it's
dangerous but but this is this is more
dangerous have you had an injury have
you ever had an injury from this never
no have you been in the room when other
people have been injured
never in the room when other people have
been injured but I have I there's always
a combination of drugs or toys when
there's an injury toys anybody like an
entire hot wheel set
Oh you mean with the track and
everything the car where did the Mustang
go So Hunger Hunger when was the first
time that you got fisted and you
realized that this was how do you say
fisting in Hebrew
good question what did you realize that
this you had an affinity for this or an
enjoyment for this or when was the first
time that you ever were fisted
I was I remember seeing it on the
internet when I had AOL when I was a kid
and um a lot of people see dance videos
Howie
oh is that porn I thought it was a sport
right a sport I mean come on yeah no so
I bumped into that on the internet and I
remember exactly what video it was and I
ended up just really being like in
enthralled with it and then as soon as I
got on
this website called Manhunt when I
turned 18 I looked for it and found a
guy to try it with and I did it on my
first try wow yeah when you say you
found the man to do it with you say if
you're interested raise your hand like
how do you know how do you know
the fisting's pretty common I mean it's
it's common so there's always typically
on like a hookup site there's a box that
says are you into this can I ask you
something I I yesterday I got a physical
and I I'll be honest I had my prostate
checked and it's the most uncomfortable
thing in the world and that's just like
a finger and the biggest the biggest
like it's uncomfortable and you feel
like you're gonna poop yourself have you
ever done that like in have you ever
have I have I mean has I ever [ __ ] when
I've been getting fisted yeah
um I'm pretty OCD and meticulous about
making sure that I don't yeah um you
have to prepare before you take you know
yeah
I spent a solid like two hours in the
shower before I got
what is that what does a shower have to
do with not being able to poop
huh uh well I mean like you're douching
oh you can overdose have you ever have
you ever overdouched we learned that
when I was younger and I didn't know my
body yeah I did what so what happened
what was your overdosing experience from
uh just a strictly uh a professional
point of view let's just say there's um
we'll just use the term trapped water
trapped water oh oh my goodness how does
it get trapped up there
the way your your insides go they're
like it's like a line here and then they
loop around and then they do like so you
know if you trap water whatever what is
the process to untrap it and when you
untrap it are you is there a possibility
of a flash flood
there's a possibility and a likelihood
of a Flash
no I've gotten the alert on my on my
iWatch once and I didn't know what it
was
yeah so hunger it wasn't from me so so
hunger you said you basically got fisted
when you turned to 18 you're you were a
performer since the age of 18 right
yeah I got um I signed in a contract
with a major porn Studio when I was 18.
and yeah and was with them for a few
years and then started my own studio and
started my own um my own brand after
that oh that's great you're an
entrepreneur I think it's great when
people in the in that industry owned
their own work it's so much better you
know oh it's like so much better to own
the Distribution on that it's just way
healthier too you guys are familiar with
only fans yeah yeah no I've never never
heard of it what is it what is that what
is only fans oh that guy I know what it
is
they kicked me off for being too too
extreme
he got kicked off of only fans that's
amazing that is amazing that's amazing
when you're kicked off of only fans I
mean isn't it for what what did they say
that what did you what line did you
cross
they're United Kingdom based and their
obscenity laws are crazy so they booted
me off
um and so I took the money that I had
earned from those sites and I built my
own build my own you know what's
interesting hunger we had Queen just
passed you think it's related
Lizzie in a box they shouldn't be
laughing no but I'm just saying you know
the song Lizzy in a box yes you do yes
wow that's pretty controversial that you
even know that Highway
we can see two on the online we could
see two girls one cup but we're not
allowed in the UK to see you two two
fists one man no three exactly
I fought tooth and nail with them but I
ended up juicing nails so I was like
I was like thinking of which hangnails
hangnails
how do you do it you gotta you gotta
probably I'm always filed yeah
these are the only file in every room in
my house but did you ever go to the do
you ever go do you go to a nail salon to
have a like a manicure
no but anybody who's pissing me I do
their nails for them
oh that's pretty fast that's good like a
bonus yeah that's great because I mean I
just look at them I mean most guys come
in they're like you think these are all
right and I'm like [ __ ] no they're not
all right you gotta go shoot you gotta
go really far down huh well also would
you ever do Lee press-ons like or a
French French tip or something like that
um no because I don't hate myself so
yeah
nothing says I love me more than having
three strangers put your fist in your
backside now how hungry
you should come on you should you should
have come on as like um event do you
have a friend that's a ventriloquist
he could drink water and you could sing
well at Jeff Dunham maybe I mean just
memories
that's not a good idea Jeff Dunham
perhaps yeah
no but uh hunger so
um that's interesting because we've had
only fans people call in to this show
who like they would [ __ ] they were
getting [ __ ] on and stuff like they they
would get requested just [ __ ] on
someone's chest and that seemed fine
with the platform it just seems a little
bit discriminatory towards gay people
yeah it just seems a little [ __ ] up so
I'm on your side there the thing was is
that my videos tend to not be so they're
extreme but they're also like I'm really
OCD about like I want to make sure that
it's it represents like a real session
like what a real like
a lot of guys I have an answer for you
thank you I've been waiting
the most hardcore extreme parts of it
and for me it's really important to show
people the warm-up the the actual
fisting right and the cleanup and social
care Aftercare so I argued with them you
know hey it's educational and they were
like [ __ ] you get off the platform no
but they don't understand how meticulous
you are and how it's it's not just about
the fist up there but it's the pre and
the prep exactly and the cleanup and the
yeah what you do they don't realize is a
service
it's educational and thank you only
you're welcome thank you thank you yeah
um thank you yeah that's true yeah well
we're not done yet what do we do about
it no I'm not saying I'm not saying
thank goodbye I was saying thank you for
what he does yes for the world yes
because I think that there are people
that can do it and it's dangerous
because they're not taking the care yes
you take exactly and they don't take it
serious like you do and they don't it's
the before and the after that they kind
of delete and then it's dangerous and
it's it is
people it gives people the perception
that um when they only see the most
extreme sex on the internet that they
are somehow like my sex life isn't valid
because it doesn't look like what I'm
seeing on the internet and so my whole
like Mo when I started was I want to
show people what it's like a real like
real no I know well I'll tell you
something and I'm just saying this is a
much older person than you your parents
raised you right hmm
do they know what you do
yeah yeah and they're okay with it right
with the yeah well I mean I'm sure that
my mom would wish I was doing something
different but I am following her to
Mexico it needs to be spending the no I
know but but but she's probably look at
my son maybe the the fists up there
isn't the moment but look at him
preparing look at the preparation look
at how he cleans up afterwards look at
the Aftercare That's my boy that's my
she's actually hunger I want to ask you
what is the um Aftercare in the and the
after scene like uh what what goes on
when the ACT is done everyone's finished
so how do we go about the cleanup and
the aftercare
the rudest thing that I feel like a top
or top can do when he's done with
fisting a bottom is to just leave them
in this Lane and be like okay we're done
goodbye so there's you wipe the lube off
of them you help you no go slower so you
wipe the poop off of them
oh you used
you're saying you helped the top or heat
the top helps you top helps you they
wipe you down yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah they make sure that you're not like
dripping Lube everywhere when you got it
you got it and and that the floor isn't
covered in Lube because then you can
slip and fall and it's dangerous people
don't realize the dangers of lube that
they say more accidents happen in the
bathroom at home than any other place
but can I tell you you tell them I don't
want to I don't want to tell them you
tell them well no I didn't mean to
interrupt I'm just saying the other day
in Mexico and I I filmed the other day
and I I went to sleep I woke up in the
you know and then and I had the bottle
of Jade the bottle of lube had tipped
over onto the tile floor when I somehow
some point when I was sleeping like I
knocked it over knocked it over but he
had he didn't have the cap he didn't
have the cap on it I didn't have a cap
on so I go to the bathroom to go pee in
the middle of the night and I [ __ ]
wiped out and you know you can have a
head injury you can have a horrible yeah
no absolutely that's why you before you
go to sleep you have to check everything
that happened to me not the exact same
thing but I posted something on Tick
Tock I went to sleep and I almost
hunger did you see Howie's Tick-Tock
because I actually you might be in a in
a position to answer this was that a
prolapse of pain or an accidental
prolapse or a intentional prolapse do
you have an insight
um I mean the guy didn't strike me as
being in pain I also don't think it was
covered related
um
but it didn't I you know it didn't it
didn't strike me I mean a couple of the
guys that I taught I mean like I don't
know I'm friends with a bunch of freaks
and then they all thought it was kind of
hot so really they thought that was a
hot picture so I was explaining to Ethan
and and you're a you're a Nikon no but I
did not know what it was I thought it
was like putting on wet shorts you
believe that huh I did not know what it
was and and I could sense that from you
I could sense that you could sense that
he knows because he's in the community
he knows that I didn't know what I was
doing you know because he's a
professional yeah and and thank you
thank you as somebody who's professional
is getting the sense that I didn't know
it was a total accident I apologize yeah
we forgive you it's okay no but I'm just
telling the community
their friends thought it was hot can I
ask you a question did they think it was
hot the photo or the fact that Howie
accidentally posted it to tick tock is
that part of the excitement no the photo
the photo yeah yeah
I mean prolapse comes that they're an
odor
odor no I mean no well how's that
possible
professionals they overdo they took a
shower for two hours they really clean
it how do you like just shooting water
is not clean I think it's he's a
professional then you wash the soap I
mean it's like you know oh you can
actually like oh you stick it out and
soapy
you don't you don't put soap on it and
you don't put soapbox that'd be painful
no but you know it's important and
you're a responsible broadcaster yeah do
not
she's calling that a genital I don't
know
I it's not I mean it's you're you're I
don't know it's the right word
it's just it's an organ organ
IC
hunger what happens
what happens so when we're at fistfest
you know we're here there's a bunch of
guys there so what happens if you
prolapse um or flowers are there food
trucks uh how we how we play this is
you're not taking this seriously I am
okay now we have one of the top
entertainers in the country here to
spread his knowledge I brought him out
specifically for you Howie because I
know that this is a passion that you're
you're interested why do you think my
question is wrong I I know it's I'm just
saying Google you know if you had
Michael Jordan or if you had uh you know
yeah Michael Jordan here to talk about
the NBA you'd listen
I'm listening I was just asking if
there's food honestly you guys
how long does a
how long does the festival last
three days three days three days wow and
so when you go there and you prolapse or
you flower if you if you will so what do
people do with the uh
with the anal anus meat oh come on
it's not I mean like I'm I'm pretty
particular about who I'm very particular
about who I let handle it because I
don't just let I mean except with the
exception of you know fisting is one
thing but that to me is like you know I
it's I understand the dangers involved
with what I'm doing and so I don't just
let anybody work at it and so you know
it's somebody that I have a connection
with the vibe with you know it's like
you know I I have to make sure that I
feel that I trust them okay because I
see it and you have time to get to know
them while you're doing their nails
exactly that's why you do their nails
and then you have a you can look at
somebody in the eye and go this is this
is somebody that I I feel good in their
hands is if they lack of seconds
within 30 seconds of playing with
someone I can tell right away whether or
not it's going to go right or wrong I
see it yeah what is the worst like give
us a a an idea of something going wrong
uh something going wrong with for me my
biggest pet peeve is a top or someone
that's missing me that tells me just
breathe oh just and what is that bother
because you don't want to break I don't
need to just breathe you need to get the
[ __ ] out of my house
I get so relate to that because I hate
and with pregnancy how much there's like
talk about breathing
it's like okay I don't know I'm just
like a baby's coming out you know what I
mean it's like
kind of the same yeah yeah
no but I get it I get it you know you go
I can see
people is jamming themselves right up
the back side of you and listen oh yeah
but and that's one thing and that's okay
don't tell me to breathe
exactly now it's kind of like also when
they tell you like uh
when you're trying to get pregnant and
you're having trouble they're like oh
you just need to reduce stress thank you
it's like okay like if that was a choice
I would choose to do you find you're not
breathing when you when this happens
no I find that they just are clueless
and like you know tell him but you
realize they're behind you so they don't
know you are it's like telling Michael
Jordan to just aim like come on dude you
know what he's doing right hunger yeah
um
is there what do people misunderstand
about you as a professional Fister what
misconceptions do you think the people
have about you that you would like the
world to maybe know and say hey this is
who I am this is what you guys
misunderstand about what I do I'm
curious if anything like that comes to
mind
that's like um I'm actually like super
super grateful that you have something
like that because it's something that
people don't ask me very often and so um
the thing is like I I have a I have
considering what I do for work I have a
ton of anxiety issues like tons of
anxiety and so like when I go to big
events and stuff
it's it's overwhelming for me sometimes
when I want to walk to get food and it
takes me two hours to get to the
cafeteria because I'm inundated with
people and I'm just like ah just like
you know so people have this concept
because they recognize you because they
recognize they recognize it yeah they
recognize me or and I'm grateful you
know I'm grateful for everything but
it's like the there's you have to
understand in the fisting world he is
like the Ben Affleck of the fisting
world no I understand that he's the he's
the big deal sorry sorry uh I am so yeah
go ahead hunger
so I basically you know it's like if I
stay in my room because I don't want to
go out and get inundated then there's
rumors why is he staying in his room and
then if I come out
and so it's like you know I'm damned if
I do it I'm damned if I don't so it's
sort of like there's this misconception
that I'm kind of elitist or that I don't
I'm not friendly but it's just that I
just get overwhelmed I'll ask every one
of us do you go to uh fiscon
fistfest fist Khan
I don't think they're the Comic-Con
that's what Fish Fest is yeah that's
what Fish Fest is yes so I sponsor I
sponsor it but I've I've since stopped
going for the last couple events oh no
yeah but I sponsor it every years or
I've sponsored every event for the last
the last several so
um I I just want to be a part of it
still but it's just it's gotten a little
too tricky for me when you get those
water when you say tricky is it because
you've become so famous in that world
that everybody wants to basically uh get
get get with you
I'm so like it's like I I want to stay
humble and not like an [ __ ] but
there's times where it does feel like
that a little bit sometimes and I'd
rather just step back and then let them
be overwhelmed like that and you say yes
you've said that you are afraid that
people in your community are thinking
that you
are uh like big-headed elitist and
that's interesting to me what people say
oh he doesn't come and he doesn't talk
to us anymore like he used to because
he's gone big time
yeah yeah that's it you understand and
it's not it at all it's just that when I
go it's like you know I feel like
sometimes I can't breathe so it's like
you know and the last one you should say
to him is just breathe right exactly
stop dude you know I love I love the
community and I love being a part of it
it's just that my my my
relationship with it has changed and
it's just you know something that I've
got you know kind of just be adapt to
it's okay so you're in Mexico you
produce content there for your website
is that your day job
um well I moved to Mexico just kind of
like I had been I've been working
non-stop for the last like four or five
years doing Hunger FF and so I just was
like you know what I deserve a [ __ ]
vacation
yeah I booked a a four months named
Mexico just to kind of get away oh nice
good that's good treat yourself you
deserve it is the painting behind you
a local Mexican artist
um well it's it's in the Airbnb so
and the name is hunger of course uh
because you hunger for for fists it's
actually a nod to the first guy that I
ever hooked up with on that website his
screen name was Hunger oh okay and so
yeah and so then when I decided to come
to do Hunger FF I was like you know I'm
like a hunger and I'll just tack the F
up on the end and that's where it came
from well there you oh you know what we
read something interesting is that the
prolapse can actually
wither over time like it can get worn
out we just read that so I don't know if
that's true or not maybe you could
correct the record for Sally was
wondering uh all things gold what was it
all things gold must end and or
something yeah something like that
Robert Frost wrote a poem about it do
you want to read him no Robert
colorectal doctors that have said that
like the problem the thing that that
would happen is if blood flow is
restricted somehow if there's a strength
strangulation of want to hear the rubber
or Frost poem
do I want to hear the phone yeah
sure if you know it my heart no I don't
know if my heart I can read it too it's
just like the music it's just um it's
beautiful hold on you're explaining that
the blood has to get cut off from the
prolapse for it to weather how does that
happen scrunchy um I mean like I mean
I don't know how that would happen I
mean like for me I mean I know that I've
been doing this for I've been I've had a
prolapse for like 17 or 18 years wow wow
and I have no problems with it I do but
you're just blessed man you are blessed
with a natural Talent there I mean that
that it's incredible how you blow that
thing overpower I'm under pricing all my
merch
I'm under pricing all my merch
sometimes I feel like I have two but I'm
not even allowed to shoot my merch I'm
sorry about that I'm sorry there's just
certain policies
you didn't do anything wrong it's just I
know how things are
and then one other thing before I read
the poem and then we'll say goodbye
thank you so much by the way for being
here what do you feel when you prolapse
your anus are you just like pushing like
you're taking a [ __ ] or is it like a
specific type of pushing right Howie
yeah do you feel like you're doing
do you go ahead
no it is a different I mean there's a
there's a way that I'll push to go to
the bathroom and there's a way that I
pushed a prolapse it's it's from two
different interesting it feels like it's
from like singing from your diet wow
when you sing from your diet like that I
just I can't I can't imagine that
pushing from there you have two
different kinds of ways to push that's
very interesting it's like an ability
that we don't have yeah I want to thank
you guys too there's I was going to say
earlier there's two ways that this I
felt like this could have gone it could
have gone a bit Sensational make me out
to be like a circus freak or to be like
really cool about this and I'm just
really grateful you guys are so like
cool about this one I I have not most
respect for what you're doing the the
path the trail you've blazed also you're
a very sweet guy you're just a very nice
dude so it's nice to connect with you
nice to talk with you uh Howie wants me
to read you this poem it's about your
music it's about the prolapse but um
actually
um your prolapse is not faded so so
listen to this drink this in Young
the first shot you did when you showed
your talent we lost the footage would
you mind uh showing it while I read the
poem
yeah
no yeah yeah no just but can you do it
like that like multiple times I mean I
can do it like yeah usually yeah I mean
Alex thank you bro Alex help me yeah go
for it go for it you're good
yeah
go for it are we good back there Dan
all right go ahead yeah just whenever
you're ready
[Music]
yeah oh I was wrong I don't know if it
comes out more
is that well it needs a little it needs
like help but not help but I mean like I
can't just like pop it out the whole way
oh okay I'm sorry I'll read the poem
I'll read the poem the poem will help
yeah maybe the poem okay yeah sorry
okay there's this poor girl that's
watching she looks horrified no
everyone's good I love it come on be
respectful to hunger she just doesn't
like I'm amazed are you kidding yeah
okay good love am I doing again yeah
yeah please please please sir yeah I'll
read the poem now I'll read the poem
I'll read the poem God yes yes hunger
it's all you
I love the underwear by the way it's
like a jock strap okay here we go uh
nature's first green is gold
her heart is Hue to hold
her early Leafs of flour
but only so an hour then Leaf subside to
Leaf so eat and sink to grief
so don goes down today Nothing Gold Can
Stay yeah
[Applause]
thank you no it's a short poem I
wouldn't do that to you I wouldn't hit
you with that like T.S Eliot like 10
pager
you're such a nice guy I'm so glad we
connected hunger you really I wish you
the best you're really a talent and I'm
glad that you you know found your own
path in life Howie do you have any
questions uh before we say goodbye to
hunger why am I here that's a question
for me everybody
it was nice to meet you
thanks for being part of the end of my
career
come on
I'm older yeah I guess I've done enough
am I okay
wiser but what you don't know
huh yeah Alex is giving thumbs up thumbs
up he's giving thumbs up no he was
signaling to me oh wait stop it should
we skip bill or thumbs up anyway hunger
let's stay in touch because I think
you're a great guy and I love I love it
so enjoy your enjoy your time off in
Mexico and uh let's stay in touch and
thank you so much for calling in and and
doing this for us I think you're
fascinating gonna break that okay
absolutely
thank you so much all right take care
take care hunger all right and there you
go I mean that was
I always stressed that was something
special that I'm being subtle about it I
was really stressed oh no how are you
feeling uncomfortable oh so that was I
had a special that was something we
actually put a lot of planning into
thank you because it's like the prolapse
episode I wanted to put it all out there
thank you you did put it all out there
not only you did he did and not and you
and it wasn't just willy-nilly it was a
beautiful like there's a lot of prep
involved and then clean up after by the
way now my son's gonna help me clean up
and by the way people are spinal it's
all educational we learned
we've learned that this is actually a
profession for him and that there is so
much that goes into doing that act
that you know we saw in The Tick Tock
thank you thank you actually
um oh my gosh yeah is this
I'm just trying to I I thought that you
know it would be great sometimes things
seem better on paper
are you talking about coming here
I don't know yeah am I is this was this
a positive Alex
oh he's just saying what's wrong he says
nothing's wrong I don't know but why
would anyone blame you for for partaking
an educational experience I just thought
we should learn
learn everything there is to know about
it and talk to the king himself and he
actually said the picture he posted was
hot
I posted a hot picture that's what he
said I'm fine people
yeah so um all right I hope I've
apologized to everybody that needed you
you didn't know if you didn't we have a
couple more things uh grab grab the
stuff I I you probably yeah I'm sure
you're
now what oh no I don't like drum rolls
they don't end with good things this
one's not that bad I probably not that
bad well oh but if you open with the
Fister guys can you post that on Twitter
the clip the uncensored Clips I'm
working on it guys wait wait what this
is gonna need to take home don't show it
though you're good
oh no Alex
Alex no this is for you Alex come it's
fine it's fine Howie it's fine
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm putting that on my podcast and I put
that in the wall in my podcast it's
censored I mean it's drawn on but that's
a painting it's a real painting a fan
right yeah uh no not Ben's name is
[Music]
that's amazing now I have a nice art
piece yeah underpriced merchandise
also we're putting out um uh trading
cards HP podcast trading cards they're
um
what's the website trade uh what is it
trading dot trading.shop it's in the
description of the episode if anybody
wants hey check those out podcast
trading cards all the revenue goes to
the crew and one of the cards we have
two one is this one
and then
it's a nice card right this is amazing
it says my friend Neil 190. I won't aim
it at the camera but this is amazing
yeah so I gotta say that listen I really
didn't know what it was I really believe
it we all believe you in fact I hope I
didn't offend anybody today I hope if
you're a sponsor and that you're not mad
at me but but uh and and I hope people
go and listen to my podcast yeah yeah
and you come back but this is the best
thing I've ever received well here we'll
give you a whole back so then this one
this is one that is a rare one it comes
only there's only a thousand of these
and they come randomly through the packs
and it comes in this sleeve how do they
buy them and it goes well so money go to
you guys to the crew yeah to the crew
well the crew I gotta say take that one
out of the sleeve because that that's
the golden Pro
it's in a sleeve so um read the warning
the H3 cards okay 18 plus 18 plus plus
congrats inside of this uh protector
lies the Elusive and rare gold prolapse
card there's really an uncensored I was
sent it
and on said that prolapsed anus inside
of this protector seriously this is an
18 plus card you've been warned please
do not open unless you want to see an
uncensored prolapsed anus peace and love
peace and love trading H3 podcast yeah
so now will you take it out of the
sleeve I just want you to see the golden
prolapse but but I think being sealed
makes it worse what more valuable yeah I
don't wanna I really want a new one
we'll get you a new one it's like a
sleeve it's open oh okay right at the
time all right how do you open it
there you go oh there I go
oh
this is amazing yeah it's beautiful I'm
not gonna turn it around
I love that you guys are so worried that
this will be seen did you see what you
guys just had up we almost saw a t-shirt
they didn't show it though yeah what was
your now when we brought yeah so that's
for you we have a full pack but those
are for you we just wanted to show you
that how meaningful this meme is
especially on all kidding aside I love
you guys I love you too I really do and
and I love your mama you know I spent
some time with your mom did you tell you
no
like I think that's how I know about the
butterflies and stuff I go to a
butterfly farm that she attends
are you serious your mother collects
butterflies she loves Monarch yes I know
that okay but she's on social media
about it you hang out is it like you
like in real life that can't be true or
is it a like your mom joke no that was
it
phone your mom phone your mom I'll call
her okay call her right now yes all
right she's gonna say no you're [ __ ]
with me no you got me no Howie what was
your response because I I thought it
would be surprising when we brought out
hunger who's such a nice guy by the way
such a great guy and he prolapsed for us
that surprised you surprised
it horrified me you know there's things
you can't unsee do you know that you
damaged me
but Howie don't you understand what I've
done that's how everyone on Tick Tock
feels it's a taste of your own medicine
in that regard oh so you went from I
didn't do anything bad it's okay they're
showing me how I ruined everything I get
it how it feels I get it so I Was Here
For My Punishment yeah here hey we're
live do you know Howie Mandel did we not
spend time and we talk about butterflies
did you hang out with Howie and
butterflies
I
wanted it to be a time I'm here I'm here
we do butterfly trading wait hi honey
are you honey
[Laughter]
could the community of butterfly correct
collectors is very small you're in the
butterfly collections yeah is it bigger
than the prolapse Community we don't
have a festival
your mom so how did you guys put meat
how did you guys meet is it on a website
or a place we were at a restaurant
Calabasas oh you ran into him with the
lady are you really into monarchs no no
no but I love your mom she's a very nice
lady and you should be proud of your son
I decided uh to retire I've been in
business forever and I allowed your son
to move and be the Catalyst to my
retirement my personal assistant I
ruined his career but he's he's being
facetious no tell her what you did yeah
how he says I brought
[Music]
no I didn't do anything I wanted to
educate everybody we brought this guy
hunger FF who is um
how are you stalking my whole family
you're running into my mom at restaurant
you're following me and Malibu oh you
went over to him okay good okay good no
I called him okay
um
I just we brought a performer out who
specializes in prolapsing and uh he
performed for Howie that's all
no Lord Oh Lord no but he's a nice guy
we learned a lot it really was a
terrific uh yeah you'd be so proud did
you you don't watch you're not watching
this live
I'm you know what I'm playing Mahjong as
a matter of fact I'm gonna have to cut
you guys short because she's gotta she's
got a bail she's got a bail all right
Mom you play for money does she play for
money all right are you playing for
money you playing for money
yeah
all right all right thank you thank you
Mom no way mother has a gambling problem
you gotta love that 41 000 people
watching listen I got I gotta go
[Laughter]
all right that was great thank you thank
you for having me did you think we could
talk for two full hours about the
prolapse because that's essentially what
we did is that a record It's gotta be I
don't know that I'm proud of this you
should be I love you guys I don't know
what I've done to myself my son will uh
talk to me on the way home for this
happened
yeah and all by the way it's on Twitter
if you guys want to watch it obviously
we couldn't show it so if you want to
and I'm on YouTube how we've been there
yeah Link in the uh description to uh
Howie's Channel
thank you
oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh Alex
help me Alex please help me Alex
what is the Alex's what do you want me
to do I don't know but you said you were
gonna give me a signal when it went too
far did you
just all of it fine people is there a
lot the second prolapse was smaller
unfortunately the first one was really
impressive and we I would imagine
everybody's really you'll really missed
the first prolapse what happened
there was a tech issue I didn't realize
but my feed because I had to record it
separately had Frozen when we had that
earlier issue so as soon as he came on I
went to go record and it was frozen and
I tried to fix it real quick but I
missed I missed the moment
well Amy did you record it on your
camera yeah yeah he was recording behind
the scenes he's got three shots of the
T-shirt though so we gotta we gotta get
the first prolapse up because that one
was the most people are saying they're
subscribing to you they're subscribing
to you subscribing to me the People by
the way the comments everyone says Howie
you're great nobody's mad at me I really
want you to know before we you're saying
you're fine people love you well your
audience you're not mad at me no no no
no no they're not well you know a [ __ ]
Bounty or whoever the [ __ ] sponsored you
yeah I don't know
they should be into prologue maybe B
will come on board my show too but I
just think everyone's saying I'm subbing
yeah everybody go subscribe to Howie's
podcast so he doesn't regret coming here
tons of people are subbing right now in
fact you have a live count Alex of
people subbing first time you said it
was over a thousand thirty seconds
you see good things happen I can't thank
you enough and right now because that's
all I have left in my career as a
podcast
I used to be on national TV I used to
I'm selling cheap shirts
oh my God
um they're good yeah so um
um yeah everyone's subbing everybody
loves you and I really I promise I
really mean it people are not mad at you
wait I never got to tell you fisting oh
yeah in Hebrew we say the same fisting
fisting yeah it took you a half an hour
to look I did I had to find out it's
called fisting I had to look up a lot
cultures wow that's amazing I had to go
I had to go to deep places of the
internet to figure it out can you fist
on Rosh Hashanah
why not feasting
[Music]
I mean
do I know who Jordan Peterson great
thinker no oh you don't know who he is
no Alex you must know who he is
huge great thinker I just want to play
an excerpt before we go of one from his
e-book I think it'll put into context
everything we've been through today try
it
Zach you you dreamed I saw my maternal
grandmother sitting by the bank of a
swimming pool which was also a river
her genital region was exposed dimly it
had the appearance of a thick mat of
hair
she was stroking herself absent-mindedly
she walked over to me with a handful of
pubic hair compacted into something
resembling a large Darkness
she pushed this at my face
I raised my arm several times to deflect
her hand
I let her have her way she struck my
face with the brush gently and said like
a child
that's I swear to God that's an answer
from Jordan Peterson's book on God and
the God so that's a great thinker out
there maybe you can get him on your pod
it's really good at poetry we've had
literature this has been a very learned
afternoon for me yeah thank you Howie I
know I really do appreciate you coming
down here and uh yeah we're we're done
you can leave now thank you well good
we're gonna wrap up show up yeah do you
like you guys uh we'll just end it yeah
thank you guys for watching that was a
great episode thank you Howie goes up to
Howie go buy his merch and uh nobody's
mad at you I swear yeah
all right
let me know if you get some calls okay
we'll we'll work it out with them yeah
yeah yeah okay how how he's just trying
to get out of here as fast as possible
Oh I thought you I watched something
thank you for watching I'm confused now
thank you guys it's been a it's been a
it's been a long two hours for you
and time flies when you're having fun
uh we'll be back tomorrow for leftovers
tomorrow morning thank you guys for
watching thank you Howie nothing left no
not and uh remember subscribe to how he
does things did I tell you I said oh
Mandel does stuff oh he does how he does
things yeah go to how he does things and
I recommend something your thumbnails
the back of your head I think you got to
turn around for it why because I'm gonna
recognize the back of your Dome
everything I do is it from the back side
[Laughter]
guys thanks for watching we'll see you
tomorrow morning Howie thank you so much
it was such a great episode I love you
love you too all right bye guys
[Music]
when my friend Neil bent over this
happened does somebody know is this
covid related and if it is what do we do
about it
ow ow